good morning my name is Bill Clark and
I'm from Johns Hopkins University School
of Medicine in the Department of
Pathology this morning I'd like to speak
with you a little bit about therapeutic
drug monitoring and cancer chemotherapy
and the opportunities that are there I
would like to remind you that during the
presentation you have the ability to
type in questions in the Q&A screen and
I'll take questions throughout the
presentation and then I'll be happy to
answer them at the end of the
presentation so today as we're talking
about therapeutic drug monitoring I
think we want to start by thinking about
how we manage drugs in general and as
you approach this you think about things
that often times it's more difficult
than we think it should be and I like
this slide because it shows different
things how we can how we can mess
something up that should be easy but
also how sometimes things can be
complicated for even gifted or smart
people and so the thing we want to do
here is talk about how we really manage
drugs in general and where does the role
of the pathology laboratory or the
chemistry laboratory play play a role in
this and so we think about how drugs are
managed in general most of the drugs
that we give their predictable in their
effects we can give a general dose most
often times these drugs are given on a
milligram per kilogram basis and this is
because we all come in different shapes
and sizes and so but in order to
normalize that out what we'll do is the
drugs will be toasted dosed on a
milligram per kilogram basis and then if
that dose doesn't have the desired
effect we'll try a different treatment
and often times that will be to increase
or decrease the dose depending on the
response or you know in addition of
additional therapeutic agent or perhaps
given a
an additional drug into that ranch minun
and we would refer this often times as
titration to clinical effect and so we
just sort of approach this
experimentally based on our past
experience the providers past experience
and then making those changes
empirically and the question that I
always ask is this is this the best way
is this the way best way to approach it
and so for many drugs actually yes this
is because these drugs are predictable
in their effects and and the dose of the
drug it corresponds well to the blood
level of the drug out of the many drugs
that are available there really only a
handful relatively that we actually need
monitoring and this is because many of
the drugs have a strong correlation
between the dose that's given and the
blood level and this means they have
that predictable behavior but in certain
cases these drugs and the blood level is
not predictable from the dose and so
depending on how much of the drug even
if the drug is given in the same
milligram per kilogram dose or or in the
case of chemotherapeutic milligrams per
unit and body surface area the blood
level can't is not predictable there's a
lot of inter individual variability and
this can be due to many factors but the
bottom line is that from the dose you
can't predict the blood level and so in
these cases the measurement of the drug
concentration is is often utilized so
when with their kid drug monitoring
you'd be useful or TDM in order for TDM
to be useful there has to be a
correlation between the blood level and
the pharmacodynamic effect now this can
be the clinical effectiveness of the
drug and the blood level or it can be a
correlation between the toxic or adverse
event and the blood level but there has
to be a direct correlation in fact
correlation doesn't exist then of course
measuring the blood level is not useful
in addition there should be a narrow
well-defined therapeutic interval
in this case what we need is that the
the difference in concentration between
the minimum effective concentration and
the toxic threshold should be relatively
narrow if that therapeutic interval is
broad that in many cases that the blood
level is not is not needed for
management of this and then we would use
the therapeutic drug monitoring or TDM
when you're not seeing the desired or
expected clinical effect or if you're
starting to observe toxic symptoms you
can also use TDM when there are changes
in drug effects or if you see and this
continued to drug drug interactions
there's some physiologic changes
disease-based changes or TBMs useful in
instances where non-compliances is
suspected the other thing that's
important to remember is that when we
have these therapeutic targets or TDM
reference intervals it's important to
think about how these are established
and in many of the cases they're
established through clinical studies but
not a large randomized control trial or
a big population based study they're
often established for single from a
single clinical site on a small number
of patients but they are in there based
on the clinical observation and their
response rates for that particular
population you know but it's important
to remember that as with all reference
animals they don't encompass every
individual or clinical situation and so
when we talk about you know from the
laboratory perspective we always
encourage the clinician to you know to
treat the nup treat the patient and not
the number and so that's that's
important that's important consideration
to remember so we think about drugs that
are typically monitored there are
several classes that you can see we have
anticonvulsant which is where the field
of TDM originated and it either
suppressants are well known and then we
have cardio active drugs some of
anti-infectives tricyclic
antidepressants set analgesics
bronchodilators HIV drugs and
antipsychotics now as the
title of the presentation is therapeutic
drug monitoring in chemotherapy or an
anti-cancer agents it's important to
note that those drugs are not on this
list chemotherapeutics for the most part
are not routinely monitored with a
couple of notable exceptions so we think
about monitoring chemotherapy drug
levels and there really are only two
instances where these drugs are
routinely monitored and there's a third
where either some biologic activity and
sometimes the metabolites are monitored
but we think about the area of
methotrexate which has been monitored
for for some time and there are
commercially available assays and then
be so fat monitoring in bone marrow
transplantation as the patients are
prepared for the bone marrow transplant
that they do some monitoring of that
drug as well in substances also they're
monitoring 6-mercaptopurine and its
metabolites or people sometimes measure
TPMT activity but in general that's
really all that's monitored for the most
part when chemotherapy agents are
administered traditional administration
is dosing according to body surface area
and this is really just comes from scale
up in preclinical studies to to
determine the best dose may be from
animal studies into into humans and then
after the the dose is given per body
surface area then the clinical response
is measured the next steps are
determined and then and then this
process is repeated which is very much
similar to the the broader approach
which is titrating the clinical effect
now if we look at the response rates
this is a paper from about ten years ago
where they reported efficacy rates for
drugs and you'll notice that that there
is no drug in terms of these classes
that is uniformly works for everyone in
the population you have your highest
number of efficacy if you see here by
the analgesics but you'll see of all
these drugs the one
has the lowest here is oncology agents
at about twenty-five percent advocacy
rate based on this review and we and if
we see that we one of the things we want
to understand is why why is that why is
it so low and there are a number of
reasons when you think about cancer and
chemotherapy right cancer is a
heterogeneous disease even for cancers
that originated in the same side of the
body there can be different mechanisms
or pathways that are altered that cause
the tumor to grow and so all cancers are
not the same and so there's a lot of
heterogeneity cancers they're all
different we have to remember that that
the people are heterogenous to right so
there's a lot of genetic variability and
there's a lot of variability and
pharmacokinetics so as people take these
drugs that can be differences in
absorption and distribution and
metabolism which can impact the exposure
of the patient to the drug and then we
know that the drugs themselves there's a
lot of heterogeneity in terms of how
they're administered and so when you
have to balance all of these things
together you'll see that it's it's it's
quite challenging and so particularly in
finding an agent that will to which the
tumor will be susceptible and as you
know there's a lot of research when we
talk about personalized medicine much of
the research is focused on the genetic
testing both in terms of genetic testing
of an organism or the tumor or genetic
testing of the person to determine
accurately determine what is the best
drug and the best dose of that drug so
we think about chemotherapeutic agents
one of the challenges is that there is
no when we think about therapeutic drug
monitoring in general we we tend to
think of a therapeutic interval or
therapeutic target but there is no drug
concentration that says if you are in
this range your tumor will respond and
that's why some of the genetic testing
is necessary of the tumors looking for
the somatic mutations but there's still
the idea is that you want to maximize
the amount of chemotherapy you can give
in order to kill the tumor without
causing adverse effects on the patient
and so the way that this was arrived is
being called the termination of maximum
tolerated dose and so what we look at is
we would say here's a starting dose
right here and that starting dose in
these political studies would be given
to three patients at at the lowest
determined starting point all right and
if these three patients do not exhibit
dose-limiting toxicity then the next
step up occurs okay and from that
perspective you will then get you'll
observe those patients and the next dose
interval and if that doesn't happen then
you move to the next dose interval and
so on and you go you come all the way
until you get here to dose what would be
considered dose-limiting toxicity and
the dose-limiting toxicity would be
where one or more of those patients
exhibits in grade 3 or 4 toxicity in
that case and that can be one or more
patients and those and then if that
happens in that three patient group that
another three patients are given the the
same dose and if one or more of those
patients exhibit in grade 3 or 4
toxicity then you step back down to this
dose so they fit that dose none of the
patients exhibiting the limited has 16
and that is defined as the maximum
tolerated dose but that's really just
the maximum tolerated dose for those
that exhibited toxicity at that level at
that recommended dose you could have
half or more of the patients not
actually getting the maximum tolerated
dose or in other words you know half of
those patients are more could perhaps be
able to withstand a higher dose of that
cancer chemotherapy which would be
desirable because you want to maximize
your exposure and so perhaps this is the
best way to do it and so what the way we
would approach is to say well if you
think about all the variability that can
be there maybe just focusing on the dose
if the dose is a predictive of the blood
concentration you may not actually be
maximizing the exposure which is which
is the desirable condition and so when
we look at the pharmacokinetic
variability in cancer chemotherapy I
think this is the figure that best ill
straits why that maximum tolerated dose
may not be the best approach so if you
recall in the in the dose administration
the drugs are really given as milligrams
or you know micrograms of drug its dose
per unit a body surface area and what
you'll see here this dotted line that
I'll point to here is that dotted line
represents in greater than 2,000
patients that is the percent CV or the
variability in body surface area and
across all the different
chemotherapeutic regimens or keeping
therapeutic agents in the patients that
were studied the the variability was
about fifteen percent now if you look at
the the bars that are in this in this
graph and this is a ghetto figure that's
about ten years old you'll see these are
common chemotherapeutic agents including
keep side of being doxorubicin orientee
cannons metabolites and when you look at
these agents you'll see even at the
lowest ones the variability in blood
concentration is around 25 to 30 percent
with some of the higher concentrations
such as the sn-38 or the active
metabolites and ranty can has a inter
individual variability of seventy
percent and so it's clear and looking at
the variability of blood concentrations
that just normalizing the body surface
area does not correct for the
interindividual variability in blood
concentrations of these agents so that
sort of goes back to the initial
criteria for therapeutic drug monitoring
which is the blood level cannot be
predicted from the from the dose and
that there's a lot of inter individual
variability so based on this it would
just seem at least on the surface that
cancer chemotherapeutic agents in
general would be good candidates for for
therapeutic drug monitoring so we want
to illustrate this using two examples
for the remainder of the time that we
have here this morning in the first
example that we will use is an older
cytotoxic
5-fluorouracil 5-fluorouracil is a
primitive analogue used in the treatment
of many different types of cancer and
the way that it works is irreversible in
addition of the enzyme thymidylate
synthase and now this drug is used in
many different it has been used in the
past as a standalone chemotherapeutic
agent and it's also used in combination
with other drugs as the basis for full
box and Port Fairy regimental men among
others and and the thing is in terms of
following this through the literature
the thing that's audience is that there
are many many emerging chemotherapeutic
regimens as people try to find the
optimal combination of drugs but there
are many regiments in which 50 years so
it's apart we know that this is
metabolized primarily by a dihydric
permitting dehydrogenase or dpd and this
is an enzyme that exhibits significant
individual variability in terms of
activity now 5 30 or so is a relatively
short half-life drug in terms of 10 to
20 minutes and it's given in different
infusion rates in future durations and
so the administration of this drug is
actually regimen dependent so how it's
given to the patient is very dependent
on what other drugs are given in
conjunction with this so we think about
this agent the first thing I want to
talk to is actually quite old it's about
15 years old and it's it's a study done
in head and neck cancer but this one is
interesting by Fetty and others this is
published in clinical cancer research in
1998 and this was a multicenter
randomized control trial featuring over
100 head and neck cancer patients and in
the study they were they looked at this
interindividual variability in blood
concentrations and a in their perception
they thought will perhaps using
pharmacokinetic allah guided therapy or
PK modifying regimen they might be able
to more effectively use the drug and so
in this case what they showed is that
they were given that patients were given
cisplatin followed by a bolus of 54
you're so followed by a 96-hour
continuous infusion and they develop
some targets based on the relation
ship of 48 hour under the curve 296 hour
under the curve so they had a
pharmacokinetic Allah guided target in
this study so the first thing that we
would look at again remember we're there
is no blood concentration for the most
part demonstrated that states that if
you achieve this the tumor will respond
remember the tumors are heterogeneous
even within the tumor there can be
different genetic polymorphisms that
have that impact the responsiveness to
the drug and so even if you do some
genotype testing on the tumor a drug
that might kill most of the tumor there
may be a small populations of cells in
which that drum will not be affected but
the goal here is to minimize the
toxicity give us drunk of much of the
drug as you can and not experience this
toxicity if we look first at the
neutropenia toxicity one of the
toxicities in five four years so as a my
low toxicity and you'll see that in the
the the white bars here in this study
these are those that were getting the PK
guided therapy whereas the darker bars
we're getting the standard regimen and
you'll see that in if you'll see in this
particular thing that there is a
statistically significant difference in
toxicity in terms of lowering the
toxicity using PK got it therapy versus
standard therapy and if you look at the
same as a mucositis which is another
significant toxicity and you'll see
another statistically significant
differences so using piqué piqué guided
therapy you do see a reduction in
neutropenia and a reduction in mucositis
so this is this is good this is
minimizing the toxicity of the drug
however in this particular study they
did not see a decrease in the digestion
toxicity although in this one it
actually looks like the digestive
toxicity is a little bit higher in the
PK Gaiden arm however that is not
statistically significant
and so they're statistically equivalent
in this case when you look at these
things so you diminish the toxicity
presumably by lowering the dose so the
question is if you have reduced some of
the exposure in order to minimize
toxicity does that decrease the efficacy
of the treatment and if you look at the
response in this case you'll see some
slight differences in both the complete
response and partial response but these
when doing a statistical test for
equivalence what the authors were able
to show is that there wasn't that these
were statistically equivalent so to
summarize that study what you'll see is
that by using PK guided dose adjustment
you're able to minimize the toxicity
while or lower the toxicity while not
losing efficacy of the treatment and so
this while not definitive in terms of
setting targets for 32 drug monitoring
it does suggest that perhaps PK got it
there to using therapeutic drug
monitoring maybe an official if we move
to next this is a study by the gamblin
group in 1998 also where they did a
prospective multicenter trial this time
150 patients with metastatic colorectal
cancer in this case the regimen was
lukewarm followed by an 8-hour
continuous infusion of my floral uracil
and they set a target range of two to
two to three thousand micrograms per
meal at steady state and this was
published in Journal of Clinical
Oncology in 1998 and when you in
summarizing the study there were several
different findings but but what's
interesting is that the number of cycles
necessary to reach that target so the
faster you're able to reach the optimal
therapeutic level was correlated with
response they will they found that if we
look here the best responders in that
particular study they were able to have
their target level achieved within one
to three courses and if we look at based
on the blood levels and this is a big
fear right that if I'm if I am you
seeing blood levels to guide the therapy
am I going to have to am I going to have
to lower the dose am I going to give
less of the drug and actually if you
look at this based on the blood levels
drawn in this 1998 study they found that
eighty percent of the patients in the
study required higher doses whereas ten
percent nine percent required lower
doses so only ten percent on the first
dose we're actually in their therapeutic
target another interesting finding was
that the good responders as over time
their plasma levels increase and what
they found that initial optimum dose to
hit the therapeutic target it still
required adjustment over time and doses
needed to be reduced once they found
that that was they were in the in the
therapeutic target and they found a
correlation between acute toxicity
levels greater than 3000 was significant
so they were able to find a threat toxic
threshold and so this would imply rather
than maximum tolerated dose you know
giving a standard starting dose at which
case in this study eighty-one percent
were below their target what they found
was that this you could use some blood
based maximum tolerated exposure
threshold and so this would say that
therapeutic drug monitoring would be
useful in terms of maximizing the
exposure while staying away from acute
toxicity and so and so these two studies
were very encouraging I believe it so
the gamblin group 10 years later went on
to publish this randomized control trial
and so this this is an interesting one
in that so they the study design you can
see on the left when they were able to
they were able to have about 200
patients and a hundred were in each arm
roughly and what you'll find is that
when they look at the overall survival
curves you'll see that in the
pharmacokinetic allah guided arm which
would be the blue level you'll see that
they had a slightly higher overall
survival than those in the standard arm
again it's not that
was equal point late so it was
approaching statistical significance but
not necessarily you know a huge impact
but again it did have some impact in
terms of pharmacokinetic Allah guided
doses and minimizing these toxicity so
these are all signs again not
definitively stating what the practice
should be but giving an opportunity to
to improve utility of our utilization of
these drugs so that some additional work
that not yet published but but
demonstrated in in abstracts that were
presented in meetings and the gamblin
group also went on to do a phase 2 study
those initial studies were done using
not the current standard of care or one
of the currently popular regimens of
full Fox without solid platinum unity
care I mean and the in the the box I'll
plant another Luke born in the 50 years
own but in this one they were looked at
two groups of patients one where they
looked at pharmacokinetic follow up in
this 120 118 patient group and then the
this 40 patient group they were looking
at those that were dosed based on body
surface area and what's interesting is
you look at the again but if you look at
this plot which is a little fuzzy but
but the take home from this is that many
of these they're very spread out so even
though they were all given me the same
dose and their target level is this a
you see of 25 you'll find that many of
the patients required dose modification
in fact fifty percent of the patients as
they showed here needed increased dose
while twenty percent require data
greaseless but there's a lot of
variability even though they were
getting the same dose based on body
surface area if you look at some of the
summary of the findings in this in this
present an abstract you'll find that if
you look at say a digestive toxicity
you'll see in Group B the PK guided goes
there was a decrease in
the diarrhea there was a significant
decrease in the mucositis a small
decrease in the hematologic toxicity and
if you look at the response again
there's a higher number of
non-responders in the standard dose
relative to be to the peak a guided
notes which implies that again some of
the non-responders and the standard dose
may have benefited if you look at the
blood concentrations relative to the
target and that data we showed on the
previous slide that perhaps they would
have benefited from many christos and
then if you look at progression see free
survival you'll see about a six month
increase in progression-free survival
and the PK guided group and then again a
six month increase in median overall
survivor in the survival in the group
that had pharmacokinetic allah guided
dosing so again this is this is data
that that's encouraging there are two
less abstracts that we want to just show
briefly one is this nürnberg study by
wilhelm and what you'll see here is this
is the number of doses that i mean i'm
sorry the number of cycles they were
showing here and you'll see the spread
in area to the curb in dose number one
in the PK assessment and as they use PK
got in therapy you'll see that this is a
much tighter group by dose for so you're
able to even though there's a large
spread by go singh by body surface area
using pharmacokinetic allah guided dose
adjustments you can then bring many of
the patients to a similar blood
concentration again this is another
abstract by west west reppin and and
their group and shows very similar right
and in sample number one you'll see a
large spread of the of the blood
concentrations or the area of exposure
by area under the curve and bios number
four you'll see that that has tightened
up significant this small number of
patients these are numerically
demonstrating so at the the
pharmacokinetic target a
you see is 20 to 24 you'll see in sample
number one only approximately three
percent of the patients initially we're
in that target range whereas by the by
sample number four almost 40% we're in
in that narrow range and if you take the
yellow range here you would have
approximately fifty percent in sample
one whereas almost ninety percent in
eighty-five percent perhaps in in my
sample for are in the recommended target
range so again this demonstrates that
that it is possible to get people to a
therapeutic target and maximize their
exposure while minimizing toxicity using
this this cytotoxic agent so um some of
the argument is that will perhaps the
challenge there you know it's
demonstrated in a cytotoxic agent but as
we move to more targeted therapies
perhaps these arguments don't hold up so
the exact example that I wanted to use
today was that of entire the tyrosine
kinase inhibitor in latinum now this is
used in treatment both for CML leukemia
and gastrointestinal stromal tumors and
in the CML the target is the BCR Abel
tyrosine kinase and in just its
targeting the c-kit it's important to
note that imatinib is metabolized by
primarily by cytochrome p450 3a4 and
five and we know that from the
cytochrome p450s there is a high degree
of inter individual variability but this
is a longer half-life drug approximately
20 hours give or take and it's given us
once-daily dosing so as this is a drug
that has a half-life of almost 24 hours
and it's given once per day we know that
these can approach that a state and so
perhaps perhaps using instead of
continuous infusion and arian of the
curve we can use a more traditional
approach to TDM which is by doing trough
monitoring in terms of moving forward as
we want to discuss some of the
pharmacokinetic allah guided therapy we
do want to
make sure to touch on the the measure of
clinical response and how do we know
that the the the treatment is working
and in leukemia the response to therapy
is actually measured through BCR Abel
transcript levels so we do have a very
robust pharmacodynamic marker that
demonstrates the clinical effectiveness
and it's it's expressed as a log
reduction from a standardized value for
untreated patients and what will note
here is that a complete cytogenetic
response is a two log reduction from the
standardized value whereas a major
molecular response is a three log
reduction and they had a complete
molecular response a remission is when
the transcripts become undetectable and
when we think about the objective of
therapy we want to show that the two log
reduction or the complete cytogenetic
response this is the major objective
milliman therapy as its been associated
with prolong survival of these patients
so if we look at this in terms of a
transcript ratio or the cumulative
incidence of what this what this is
showing is that a three months after
after therapy is initiated if the
3-month transcript ratio is less than
0.6 one percent that indicates if you
look at the cumulative incident of
complete molecular response or
undetectable transcripts you'll see out
of eight years the cumulative incidence
of cmr gets up over eighty percent based
on this paper whereas if the three
months transcript ratio of greater than
point six one percent you'll see that
the probability of achieving complete
molecular responses is much much lower
and and what this demonstrates is that
it's important to optimize the response
to therapy early on you want to maximize
the clinical effect of this drug within
that first three month period and
perhaps one of the ways to do that is to
maximize exposure using using
therapeutic drug monitoring so this is a
summary slide from two papers by
takahashi and what we'll start with is
actually
this figure in the in the upper
right-hand corner of the slide and what
you'll see here is that there are four
dosing categories or four bins and
you'll see that there's the greater than
400 milligrams less than 300 milligrams
and then exact doses of three and four
hundred milligrams what you'll see is
patients getting greater than 400
milligrams and you'll see there ranging
from a c-major trough concentration of
less than a thousand data graphs per mil
up to a much greater than 280 grams per
meal but that's quite a spread and if we
look at if we look at the will clear
these and we'll look at the spread of
those receiving less than 300 milligrams
you'll see that there's a constant they
range of concentration from there to
there and then those on three and four
hundred nanograms per mil spread all the
way from here to here alright so that's
a that's a lot of inter individual
variability in patients taking these
drugs in terms of the blood
concentration so a number of patients
and their and their trop concentration
by dose and so there's a lot of
variability there now if we look in this
figure to the left you'll see this is a
table summarizing some studies that had
been done previously including the mayor
and study that we refer to earlier and
what you'll see is that they they looked
at the number of patients range in
premise view as 18 to 22 as many as 250
and what they demonstrate is that they
look at the dose and then the trough
concentration of a man and and what
you'll see is that ranges from seven
hundred to a thousand or 1500 and
they're looking at the the correlation
with responses they find it in a
majority of these studies that achieving
this target where this listed imatinib
trough concentration is correlated with
response to the drug and if you look at
the data summary slide in the lower
right-hand corner here what you'll find
is that in this in a number of patients
that had greater than 1,000 nanograms
per milliliter trough concentration 75%
of the
was roughly achieved major molecular
response or the log 3 reduction whereas
in the patient group with trough
concentrations less than 1,000 nanograms
per mil only had a major molecular
response of fifty-nine percent so again
it's not a definitive it's not a certain
black and white but it does seem to to
demonstrate that there would be some
improvement by maximizing this exposure
to the drug now because this is an
orally given agent that can be given it
in an outpatient setting is you know you
can take it home and take it daily like
an HIV medication or even a daily
vitamin there is some concern about
whether patients will continue to take
the drug whether that's because it's a
coughs a cost-saving measure or whether
it's because people don't like to take
pills and they feel like they're getting
a positive report from the position or
whether they are just feeling better
maybe they feel like they don't need to
take the drug and so at this particular
study by marin in 2010 wanted to look at
it here its verses non adherence and so
what they did this is an interesting
study when they measured adherence in
one of two ways number one they did the
pill counting and which makes sense
right if you're gone if it's 30 days
between appointments you should have
taken 30 pills it's given once per day
but the other way that they were able to
do this was monitoring adherence by
something called mems okay the meds cap
is a radio frequency device that is that
is put into the cap of a pill bottle and
it records every time that pill bottle
is open and so in this study the
patients were told about patil counting
but not the men's system and then the
clinical response was measured by was
assessed by measuring the BCR Abel
transcript and what's interesting about
this is that so they'd be able to tell
let's say again hypothetically numbers
30 days between appointments they would
be able to tell whether somebody just
open the bottle once or twice and then
jump down a bunch of pills and whether
they actually took 30 pills and open the
model 30 times you'd really have to work
at it if you were trying to fool
somebody with the system so anyway as
they measure the adherence using both
the man's and Hill County and they
measured clinical response they also
looked at plasma concentrations and some
genetic mutations as well but the
findings are very interesting when they
look at adherence so if patients were if
we look at the top panel here pale a we
see this is the proper probability of
major molecular response to the log 3
reduction the three log reduction in
transcript and you'll see that patients
that were greater than ninety percent
adherence and this was only 60 out of
the 80 to 90 patients 65 maybe you'll
see that the probability over several
months is quite high getting up over
eighty percent that they would achieve
the major molecular response and in
those that were less than ninety percent
adherent you'll see that that
probability is much much lower now it's
important to note in this that when you
look at you see that some are still
achieving the major molecular response
it's important to note that this could
be people that are 10 or 0% adherent
versus somebody who is eighty percent
adherence so that's quite a heterogenous
mix compared to the top blue line if we
go to probability of a 4 log Risk
Reduction again you can see that the
probability of obtaining this reduction
is much higher for those patients
greater than ninety percent adherent
versus those that aren't taking their
drugs and again if you go all the way
down to the complete molecular response
or PLC you'll see that you have
virtually no chance of getting in
complete molecular response if you're
not adherent to your medication now
another interesting finding in this
paper as we look at the study here you
look at the adherence rate and again
we'll look at major molecular response
percentage of those getting is
ninety-three percent for those that are
greater than ninety percent and here it
whereas major molecular response was
seen in about fourteen percent of the
patients that were less than ninety
percent in here so that that tells a
good story but the other thing I wanted
to point out in this paper is look at
look at the amended plasma level which
was not the goal of the study but if
they look at major molecular response
eighty percent of those patients greater
than eighty percent had a plasma level
of greater than one microgram per mil
which is a thousand nanograms per know
so this correlates with the previous
studies whereas those that were achieved
major molecular response you'd see
sixty percent were had less than or the
sixty percent that got major molecular
response were actually less than 1,000
nanograms per meal if you go all the way
out to a complete molecular response
you'll find that forty percent of those
the forty percent that got complete
molecular response had greater than a
thousand Ava grams per mil whereas you
had that twenty percent incomplete
molecular response that had less than
1,000 nanograms per mil so so clearly
there's something about perhaps this
trough level that is that is significant
and then if we shift to that was in
leukemia and we'll shift into and to one
last study where we look at a magnum TDM
in gastrointestinal stromal tumors and
in this particular study by Demetria and
his news group and they looked at
patients randomly assigned to either
received four hundred milligrams or 600
milligrams daily and then in a subset of
patients where they were able to have
full PK data and which was about seven
patients and they were they would took a
look at this plasma exposure and the
clinical outcome and and the way they
approached it was to look at not looking
at a specific concentration because it
wasn't PK gotten therapy this is a
retrospective analysis but they they
grouped the patients into quartiles and
then they assess the plasma
concentration and are the plasma
exposure relative to the various
outcomes time to progression and also
they did some genotyping now it's
interesting is if you look at both for
the weather a couple of interesting
things here you'll see that both for the
the four hundred milligram at six
hundred milligram dose they're sprinkled
throughout this concentration range
you'll see that you have some as low as
you know 500c man all the way up to four
greater than 4,000 see men but what
you'll see is that there are blue and
yellow everywhere so it's it's quite a
spread as we demonstrated in multiple
discussions of this but but so you'll
see and then the quartile and i want to
point this out as well as at this break
right here between the third and fourth
quartile it seems to be at about a
thousand anagrams Pramila in your brain
as we discuss the results so we look at
the analysis by quartile what you'll see
in the quartile number one there were if
you add up all the best benefit here you
look at all patients you'll see that in
quartile 1 and you had about sixty-seven
percent versus eighty percent in the top
three quartiles eighty to eighty-five
percent now if you look at those with a
beneficial mutation in quartiles two
through four you see a hundred percent
response whereas only a 67% response
there and if you look at an adverse
mutation something that seems to have
indicate poorer response to the drug
this secant X on nine attention what's
interesting is the highest quartile
which is only one patient so you can't
just cross it to school conclusion but
that that one patient who had the best
result was in court i'll for whereas
quartiles 1 through 3 seem to have the
similar a similar response and so that
would seem to indicate that perhaps
you'll get the best response in this
adverse mutation or non favorable
genotype by having the by maximizing the
exposure but again in the other the
favorable mutation in the overall group
there seems to be that cut point between
quartile 1 and the upper three quartiles
and about a thousand anagrams from well
again it's evidence that's applying it's
not making a definitive case necessarily
but it's implying that getting that
seemed in over 1,000 nanograms per mil
is a positive
a positive indicator of a response to
the best response to the drug this is
just a graphical showing time to
progression you'll see the upper three
quartiles are significantly different
than the lower quartile looking at time
to progression through day 29 I'm sorry
based on a day 29 trophic level it's so
to draw this to a close the question is
is there you know is there an
opportunity for this rational management
of chemotherapy using using blood levels
and when we think about precision
medicine or personalized medicine as a
whole you know I certainly win in
approaching this I wouldn't posit that
therapeutic drug monitoring solves all
the problems for chemotherapy math era p
management there clearly needs to be
more research and developing new drugs
and also in this the genotyping research
that's going on the genomic research
that's identifying new therapeutic
targets as well if I as well as
identifying tumors that are susceptible
to these chemotherapeutic agents that's
vital research and very important in
fact I think that's the top of the
pyramid in terms of identifying which
drug gives you the best chance of
success and perhaps the genetic testing
can also help you determine a starting
dose but i think that there's room in
oncology and elsewhere to then once that
pre therapeutic testing is done after
initiation of the chemotherapy there's a
role for using the drug levels or what
we would call the classic therapeutic
drug monitoring to help maximize the
exposure to that therapy and then
developing better mile markers to
determine more rapidly whether what what
we think of that optimal dose and an
optimal drug whether that's working the
way we think it should so the biomarker
is vital and I think by taking all three
of those components that's where we
would turn the TDM from monitoring into
management where all three of these
laboratory measurements are vital in
terms of of guiding this chemotherapy an
example of this could actually be found
this is an article by judson and Clinton
cancer research not so long ago and I
think it illustrates this this approach
quite quite nicely where so this is in
the
the context of just a therapy and if you
look at so the initial one is a genotype
so this was me that pharmacogenetic
testing and we would look for the X on
nine or the exon 11 mutations and kit so
in this case let's let's first head to
the right so we look at this the
pharmacogenetic testing would show at
imatinib sensitive genotype or an exon
11 k so in that case we would determine
the starting those four hundred
milligram but also do the
pharmacokinetic monitoring to optimize
the exposure what's that exposures been
optimized that we would do the response
assessment as we mentioned we want to
make sure that we're getting those BCR
Abel transcripts down and if that if
we're seeing the the good response right
and we would repeat the PK study if we
see the good response that we continue
the therapy at that at that initial
level if there's a poor response then
perhaps we want to evaluate the PK and
if the trough is low that may indicate
either some drug-drug interaction or
other change the pharmacokinetics or it
may simply indicate non-compliance but
if you're seeing a progression or poor
response you want to evaluate the
pharmacokinetics if it's not a non
compliance issue then you may want to
increase consider either a dose increase
or a change to a different agent now if
we go back to the beginning and look at
the left side perhaps in that initial
pharmacogenetic maybe that initial
pharmacogenetic test we look at that and
say well gosh it's um it's not something
that's going to be a mat and sensitive
in fact if we have something like say
the the exon nine mutation perhaps we
want to then just go to high dose
imatinib without the PK assessment with
or without the PKS estimate but it's not
the ex ein nine then perhaps we want to
consider it but some other resistant
gene type perhaps we would consider a
different different therapeutic approach
but but in this way we're using all
three of those were using the genetic
testing for somatic mutations we're
using some pharmacokinetic assessment
and also using that biomarker to
determine whether we're we're seeing a
response to therapy and with that what
we'd show is that you know certainly
that therapy drug monitoring in these
pharmacokinetic studies are not the the
Sistine Chapel ceiling but but certainly
it's important to lay a floor for that
so that you can get to be to that
important work on top so it's one of the
steps we think to lay the building
blocks to perhaps optimize response to
chemotherapy and not limit our idea of
laboratory testing to optimize therapy
only to the genetics i think that
there's a room for other phenotypic
testing as well and with that I'll be
happy to take questions at this point
and let's see in question number one
what I see here is actually a request
for my email if there are any questions
and and I I believe that's on the that's
on the final slide here so I'll move on
to the next question which says oh here
why don't we use a TDM instead of
grossing for many clinical purposes BSA
is a better indicator metabolic mass
than body weight because it's less
affected by abnormal atom's mass in
addition there's a four to ten fold
variation cytotoxic drug clearance
between individuals two different
activity and drug elimination processes
what do you think about it and what is
your personal experience so I guess the
question is that the the the the
questioner has sort of observed the same
thing as we laid out in the slides that
there is a significant amount of inter
individual variability and this seems to
indicate that perhaps we would benefit
from maximizing exposure in terms of
what I think about i hope i hope that
it's obvious that that i do think that
there is a role but there are studies
needed and unfortunately you know we
talked about my personal experience is
that this doesn't really happen except
in those very specific circumstances
such as methotrexate abuse so fun i
think for the most part this isn't
really used and it's because further
studies are needed you know some of
these studies imply a role for TDM but
it's still not definitive you know there
are
and full of randomized control trials
for this but you're competing for
patients right so many people in
academics are looking for the next great
drug and you know that's that's where
they're getting their money that's where
they're going to get the academic
promotion that's where the funding is
there aren't a lot of people lining up
to optoma you know to fund studies to
look at ways to optimize you know a 50
or 60 year old drug and so I think
that's a challenges in terms of how do
we get these studies set up and how do
we get them funded in the United States
I'm not aware of a lot of this work
going on I know that in Europe there are
multiple studies on going with flora so
as we demonstrated there's some studies
on going with imatinib and then the
taxanes paclitaxel and docetaxel that
are looking at specifically how can we
manage the taxanes and other drugs
better just using pharmacokinetic
llegando singh and so i think that there
is growing interest you see the
literature more and more discussion of
this topic but it's still not mature and
I think a lot of studies are needed but
I think that there is a certain amount
of resistance to doing this because it's
not something that people are used to
doing in in the area of epilepsy there
are a lot of people that are used to
doing therapy to drug monitoring so it's
sort of accepted but in in oncology this
isn't routine practice and I think
people are are skeptical or not certain
of how they would incorporate it into
them into their practice the next
question we have is it talks about it
says lots of people have a weekly or
monthly pillbox that they put their
pills in once a week or once a month to
help them remember whether they took it
or not did they take this into account
it wasn't clear from the study I think
that III didn't see any mention of a
reminder pillbox in the context of the
study I think that they gave them the
bottle of pills but you're correct that
would be a complicating factor which is
if they removed all the pills at once to
put into their pill box perhaps that
would complicate things and I think that
that that would either be addressed in
the patient interview and they would be
aware of it
that way or perhaps that's something
that would indicate non-compliance when
there was done so that could be a
complicating factor to the data
interpretation but that's not something
that I have a strong knowledge of in
terms of how that was incorporated into
their interpretation of data okay the
next question it says I think this kind
of study cannot be generalized and
depends on the specific individual
what's your view on this I I think I
think that that's exactly right that
therapeutic drug monitoring is not the
catch-all to I'm assuming you're talking
about therapeutic drug monitoring
studies in general and what I would say
is that needing to assess the drug
response on an individual basis and in
the optimal dosage on individual paces
is the entire point for this that you
need to be able to look at the blood
concentrations and the response for a
first for a single patient I think that
if you look at this very broadly and you
see that TDM can be a tool it certainly
doesn't mean that your treatment will be
successful and I think the again every
time that I speak a position on a
clinical consult I would always tell
them you close with the exact same line
which is you treat the patient and not
the number so while the TDM result is a
tool for helping interpret the bigger
picture it does need to be interpreted
to be interpreted in light of the
specific individual my view is that you
need as much information as you can get
you want to look at the pharmacokinetics
you can't look at you can't just assume
that you have a picture of the
pharmacokinetics because you have the
cytochrome p450 genotype because there
are so many other things that can impact
the pharmacokinetics diet
the body mass and body distribution then
any drug-drug interaction so those are
all pieces that have to be taken into
account for that specific interment it
individual to assess the pharmacokinetic
result and then same with the biomarker
so I think that getting the oncologist
or provider the most information they
can get both in terms of genotyping and
the phenotyping with pharmacokinetics
and the biomarkers that gives them
information to interpret the specific
individual clinical presentation so I
think that you're absolutely right that
you need to to use the you need to take
these I don't want to say with a grain
of salt but you have to take this
information as something that can help
and not just be plugged into an
algorithm and says oh I have this
genotype this pharmacokinetic number
therefore I make this clinical decision
there is absolutely what you know from a
laboratory perspective it's not our
intention to take any of the judgement
away from the provider because they're
the ones who have the direct interaction
with a specific individual patient and
they're the ones who have to make the
decision so I think you cannot
generalize it and you must take that
information and use it as a tool to
individualize therapy for a specific
patient okay if there are no more
questions feel free to email me at any
time and i'll be happy to interact with
you offline thank you so much
oh I apologize we didn't finish it I do
need to put up the educational credit
link if you would like to get the CME
credit or the CT credit please go to the
bio conference alive calm website thank
you very much